- Welcoming for a fireside chat,
Christopher Bishop and Harry Shum.
- Great.
Harry first of all, thanks hugely for taking
the time to join us.
- Of course.
- I know you've had an incredibly busy day in just,
I guess you've literally
just flown back in to Seattle so.
- Yeah, you're right.
Well first of all, congratulations Chris both
for the incredible lab
you have built over
20 years in Cambridge,
and of course,
nothing beats this great honor
of the Royal Society,
signing on the same book as Newton.
It's an incredible achievement.
I just came back about two hours ago.
I was this morning at this big Microsoft
internal event we call Ready.
This is actually a week-long
event for our sales force.
Half of our company, roughly half of our company
is actually working on the sales and marketing side.
Every year we use this opportunity
to share with our field,
the sales force what's happening in the company,
and we also live broadcast
all those presentations
from the conference
and across the company.
It happens to be in Vegas.
It's only 114 degrees there.
It's just incredible.
I hardly went outside.
So I was so happy to come back to join
you and the Faculty Summit.
- That's great you could be here.
So I thought we would have maybe 20 minutes or so,
you and I have a bit of chat about AI,
and then I'll open it up to the audience.
So please, be thinking of some interesting questions
on the topic of AI for Harry.
Maybe I can just dive right in and I'm going
to start with a fairly tough question.
But maybe I can just dive right in.
And I'm going to start
with a fairly tough question.
This is a bit like asking parents
about their favorite child or something.
I mean, there's a lot of work in
MSR worldwide around AI, but are there any things
that particularly stand out?
- That's really a tough one.
And I guess if I can pick just one,
the rest will be easy.
There's just so many exciting things going on in
MSR, and I feel extremely fortunate and very proud
of what we have done in the last 26 years.
In MSR there are actually three areas
I recently got very excited about it,
and not surprisingly, you would agree
that AI is certainly one of them.
I will get to that later.
Two other areas I feel very, very excited about,
and one is actually a very forward looking,
and the other one is also very timely.
The one very forward
looking is quantum computing.
We have been working on the Station
Q, quantum computing for a long, long time.
I think we're getting to a point that we feel
we're getting very close
to get the stable qubits that we can produce.
Certainly, you know Mike Friedman will be able
to tell you a lot more details.
One thing I can share with you
is that we feel so confident
that we actually started
to really work
with experimental physicists
to really get to the physics level,
how can we construct those qubits?
Once you get enough of those qubits,
then great things can happen.
The other area I feel very, very excited about,
and they're very timely for Microsoft
is on security and the privacy.
Specifically on security, this incredible initiative
across all our labs, certainly you know,
Cambridge Lab as well as on this path,
what we call the confidential
computing and the secure computing.
And the idea there is really that, you know,
not only can do encryption at rest and on the go,
but also during computation.
So this has been a very exciting research area
for us over quite a few years.
It's fantastic to see we have an opportunity
to move that technology into Microsoft products.
Certainly I want
- That's very relevant for AI, of course.
- Absolutely.
- But also data driven and we care
about the privacy and security.
- Yeah, it has profound impact over many,
many things that we want to do at Microsoft.
And the AI, of course,
there are many things that we do.
I heard Eric give a fantastic
presentation this morning,
and I had the opportunity
to go through his slides earlier.
We do many things, and I'm not going
to talk about a lot of things
that Eric mentioned about it,
I will just bring a couple of examples
of where I see great
MSR research having incredible
impact on the products.
You know, one of those areas
is actually machine reading.
A lot of interesting things
happening in natural language,
and that we as a company deal
with a lot of text,
whether it's email, web page,
or even any kind of documents.
There's so much that we can do,
we absolutely are working hard on that.
Office 365, Outlook, Word and many
of those things will depend on a lot of
MSR technology along this line
we loosely call the machine
reading comprehension.
The other areas actually are probably
a little bit of personal bias
is really the connection
between the visual images,
videos and natural
language description.
Sometimes call them captions;
captions from image, captions from video.
I think true image understanding
has to be connected with natural language.
- And you're giving a keynote,
aren't you, next week is it?
- Well actually, this Sunday.
- This Sunday.
- It's a little bit embarrassing.
I was invited to go give keynotes at the CVPR,
which used to be my main conference until 2007.
I believe 2007 was the last time
I really participated at the CVPR.
This time I got a chance to go
attend again and they gave a keynote.
And they are mostly really about sharing
some lessons that we have learned from Microsoft.
The title of my talk is
called Commercializing Computer Vision.
So I will talk about a few examples,
including HoloLens,
how we actually organize research efforts,
how we actually do move the research
to the product side
and with the flywheel.
- That's great.
Actually, that's a good hook into my next question,
which is, sort of step back a little bit
and a few months ago,
the company created this new organization, AI&R,
and appointed you
as the leader of this.
So can you tell us a little bit
about AI&R and its mission?
- Yeah.
Well, I am incredibly excited about and very honored
to have this opportunity to lead to AI&R for Microsoft.
AI&R is actually our force
engineering division and the research division.
- And the R is research.
- R is research, AI and the research.
The other three parts of engineering groups,
in case you don't know and are curious,
those three are Windows
and devices, Office productivity
and clouds and enterprise.
AI and the research is the fourth one,
and the latest and the smallest one, actually.
We only have 7,500 people in our division.
But it's very timely and important
for the company as you see the incredible progress
that has been made in the last several years,
in particular in AI.
Many areas of AI, many of those
great examples this morning
from Eric you've already seen,
but we feel this is really the right time
to not only do the greater research,
but also really having impacts
on Microsoft business.
First of all through products
and the services and the opportunities
to really democratize AI technology
to third parties
to our customers.
So that is then
the really starting point.
And recently I have had
a lot of opportunities talking
to many people
outside of Microsoft
as well,
including many CEOs,
CTOs, and the
engineering leaders.
Everyone's just so excited about AI,
and also so worried about, you know,
what if we miss this AI thing
I think there's certainly
a lot of hype over there.
My joke is that you know, you have
to claim that you like and that you do AI,
artificial intelligence,
because the opposite
of artificial intelligence
is natural stupidity.
So you just have to say it.
You know, if you don't do AI,
what else did you do?
So that's a problem.
And but seriously,
on a more serious note,
we really believe there are great
opportunities for the company
and for our customers,
even more importantly.
- And anything in particular?
Any particular products or services
that you see coming along?
- Yeah, I'd be happy to share more on that.
So the way we think about with the AI
and the research division
is really about what kind of products
and services that we can offer.
So by and large, we think about those
three lines of products that we built.
The first one is really
the first party AI products
that probably few know, reasonable.
Along the line of say, search engine
Bing and the digital assistants like Cortana.
I certainly very much believe
in that, that ultimate form of AI
is actually in digital assistants,
in the right place, right time
with the right information,
helping you to do right things.
It's still very, very early.
Along that line we actually do
very good work on chat bots.
So we have been building chat bots
like no one else, and especially we start from China.
Great success, then we were
doing Rena in Japan,
Zoe in the United States,
and we did Raul in India.
So we continue to expand our effort.
So this is one line of products
that we feel very committed in the long term
and will keep pushing.
The second line of products,
also very reasonable for Microsoft
taking on is what we called infusing AI
into every single product
and service Microsoft offers,
especially with Office.
Imagine that with PowerPoint, you know,
we already embedded
in a machine translation
to PowerPoint,
you know, when you do
PowerPoint presentations, the audience,
depending on what kind
of languages they like,
they can tune in to that language.
Another thing we actually incorporated into PowerPoint
is actually image caching.
So now when you import
an image into PowerPoint, you know,
immediately we can
offer you image
captions if we feel confident
If we are not confident
after analyzing the picture,
we might be confident enough
to show you some entities
detected from the image.
So it's still very early.
But with PowerPoint,
we actually every day
we actually have
10 million images
that actually get captioned.
And we also have Word, PowerPoint and
many other things that we can do.
The great work from your lab,
for example, with the Excel,
what we are doing
as you import data
into various cells,
you know, what kind of things
we can process there
using some machine
learning and AI tech.
So that's really second line
of work that we do.
And I should also mention about
really applying AI into our cloud.
Azure is becoming the most intelligent cloud,
literally, if you look at what kind of AI
capabilities we can offer there.
The third line of products
that I would say is pretty new
and is something
that I have thought
of long and hard,
and have decided that we have to take that
on is really the new
and the emerging
business processes.
As we think about all different
kinds of verticals
and all different
vertical industries
and all different kind of
horizontal business processes,
I certainly believe that they will
all be disrupted by AI and the data.
That the vertical industries
like health, health care, something you,
Peter and Chris Jones
have been working on,
it's just so obvious
that we should get in
and apply our AI technology
to challenges
and with what business model
and how should we think
about a partnership?
And as we think about the horizontals,
it is maybe even more interesting.
In all the business processes,
so we actually deal with today
like sales and marketing,
like customer support
and customer services,
like HR and recruiting,
all those things
will be transformed.
It's just so obvious, so obvious,
it should be in everyone's mind.
Now you actually have the data.
Now we actually can do the process,
now you can apply AI.
So those things, in my mind,
would be low-hanging fruits, so to speak,
if you care about
creating a new business.
So those three directions are what
we are now focused on in Microsoft,
especially for AI&R.
But it's really not just us.
We work together with other parts of the company.
- That's great.
An amazing time to be in the field.
- Absolutely.
- There's so much happening.
- Let me ask you a little bit
about Microsoft in particular.
How would you say that Microsoft's approach to AI
perhaps differs from those of others?
What makes Microsoft special when it comes to AI?
- Well Chris, I would start by asking
a slightly more general question.
What is special about Microsoft?
I think every company has its own culture,
has its own mission, has its own point of view.
You know, why should we exist?
You know, Satya was very clear that
we should always question ourselves.
What would people miss if we simply
just disappear as a company?
I think we are very, very clear that we exist
to serve other people in other companies.
Our company mission statement
is incredibly crisp, in my opinion.
That's empower every person and every organization
on the planet to achieve more, now with AI.
So that is really the high level,
guiding principle.
So do that with AI.
And more specifically, I would say
if you look at our position, our assets,
our history,
I think we approach AI
with a very practical approach,
yet with long-term commitment.
I start with long-term commitment.
So we started Microsoft
Research 26 years ago.
At that time, you know, Bill Gates said,
"Wow, wouldn't it be nice, you know,
someday computers could see,
hear, talk and understand
human beings."
What is that?
Those computers are called AIs.
So most people don't know that among
the first groups we ever started in the Redmond Lab,
that's the first lab we ever started.
The first three groups were the natural language
group, speech group and the computer vision group.
So we started that 26 years ago,
anticipating AI would make great
progress in the general AI,
and work towards general AI.
We definitely continue to have
this commitment and the confidence.
We will continue to invest in research,
really take on those very tough problems.
The question that you always want
to address in that area,
that you and many others, care about
and we will continue
to push that.
Yet at the same time, I would say,
we do have those products
that can infuse AI
to immediately help
our customers.
I already mentioned about PowerPoint,
I already mentioned about cloud and also Excel,
you can imagine that Word
would become more intelligent.
Word should become a reading
and writing tool much more intelligent than today.
Even more interesting to me,
you know, my favorite application
nowadays of AI
is actually Outlook.
There's really no reason why
Outlook search is so difficult,
and a smart reply
is not very smart.
Reminders are not very intelligent.
All those things now,
we AI&R work together
with Office teams very,
very closely.
So I would say that first of all
we have our own company's mission
and that really guides our AI work,
and then we are both practical
in the long term.
- That sounds great.
So lots of opportunities then for AI.
What about the other side?
What about the risks associated?
I mean do you wake up at 3 am worried
about killer robots and lasers?
Do you see any risks in AI?
- I do.
I don't worry about those products, yeah.
There are many things
that we should worry about,
But I'm not too worried about
things like super intelligence and AI,
but there are practical things
that we do need to worry
about in my opinion.
The first thing I would say, probably is
whatever AI applied to the physical world,
a concrete example
is actually self-driving cars.
I would predict that the most challenging time would be
when half of those cars on the street are self-driving,
and half of them
are still human driving.
I don't think we really understand enough yet.
I think we are fooling ourselves, just so you know,
today, autonomous driving is already there.
It's just going to take some time.
I learned something just a couple of weeks ago
at the MIT advisory board meeting.
Rodney Brooks was there talking about the robotics
and inevitably one of the topics
there was actually self-driving.
And he defined the standard
in his point of view, he's actually very cautious about
how soon we would see autonomous
driving cars there.
His counter-argument is straightforward.
He said look, if you drive in Cambridge, Boston.
The fake Cambridge, you know,
not the real one.
So if you're driving in Cambridge,
you really couldn't drive
if you don't violate
the traffic laws.
Now how do you program into that?
And I think that is something
that we're still learning.
It's still very, very early
and the direction is very clear.
It's just about the staging.
The other thing, you know, we as a company,
as an industry worry
about is the profound impact with AI,
with automation,
that we will see on the job market.
I think every technology disruption,
every technology innovation, we have certain impacts.
But this time I think people
tend to believe this thing
is probably going to be
more real than others.
We don't understand what kind of new jobs
it will open up.
We already see some jobs
will be transformed.
So those are the things that actually
we worry about as a company.
And maybe the last thing I personally, you know,
worry about AI, not much about super intelligence,
is really that the reason AI
is so different from many
other incredible innovations
in the history of human being,
is that most of
the previous innovations,
there's much about extending
human physical capability.
And this time with AI, we're talking
about extending brain powers as well.
Yet, we don't really
understand the human brains.
And the neuroscience is still, in my opinion,
still very much early stage.
So something that we will keep learning.
- Yeah, that's very interesting.
I think actually also there's a risk the other way,
there's a risk of things
that may not go as well as we hope.
But I wonder also that with very justifiable concerns
about the danger about privacy and security
and so on, that we might go too far
in the other direction,
and then actually,
I mean, take for instance
in the health care space,
for instance.
There's tremendous societal benefit
that we can see is potential
that is latent there in AI,
and we may shut that out
if we overreact to some of these risks.
So it feels like we need to find
the right sort of middle ground here.
- Right.
I think that one small step toward that,
and first of all, I totally agree with you on that.
A very small step towards that, we have been learning
through the development of many AI products,
especially through our chat bots,
is really this whole AI thing
is not just about IQ intelligence.
It has a lot, what it's all about,
that is about smart.
It is actually more about empathy
and understanding.
You know just like humans, like EQ.
So something that we are still learning,
you know, what does this even mean?
And when you interact with a human being,
when did you make this kind of recommendation?
When did you interrupt?
And a lot of this I think
this is still very, very early.
My favorite example is actually I was
talking to the XiaoIce team in Beijing,
and the chat bot knows where this person
is roughly through IP and others.
Let's just say that it's already 1:00 a.m.
in the morning, and this person
keeps talking to the chat bot.
So should the chat bot slow down the response?
Should chat bot say, oh, you should go back to sleep?
What if it's already 2:00 a.m.?
What if it's actually 3 a.m.?
Does the chat bot have any responsibility?
So those things, we just, are very, very early.
So we just have to really learn along the way,
you know, how to design these kind of AI products.
- Yes really interesting.
And of course,
it needs input from lots
of different disciplines,
right, not just from
IT technologists.
You know, social scientists
and many, many others.
I'm conscious of the time.
I'm keen to open this up to questions.
But there's just one more question
I think I'd like to touch on,
because I know this is of tremendous
interest not just to Microsoft,
or the whole IT industry,
but to industry generally,
and of course the academic world.
Which is this extraordinary explosion
we've seen in demand for talent in this space.
And what are your thoughts on the
talent pipeline and what we could do?
- Well this is truly amazing to see
how excited people are about AI.
You know first of all, then how hungry
the companies are hiring AI talent.
We all know that the price tag
is just sky high.
Not too long ago I was at a forum
and I said to the press, I said look.
Nowadays, if a young kid knows how
to train five layers of Neural Net,
the kid can absolutely
demand six figures.
If the kid can train 50 layers of Neural Net,
the kid probably will want seven figures.
So it's just that the talent market
is very, very hot out there.
I think this is where we should
work together with academia to train
the next generation of AI talents,
so students really know what to do,
what kind of tools they can do.
At the same time Microsoft,
companies like Microsoft,
have responsibilities to come up
with the right tools.
Like in Microsoft we certainly do,
we actually do the two kinds of tools.
One is actually for developers.
They are the ones actually
for data scientists.
And for data scientists we have Azure machine learning
go all the way, end-to-end, how we train those models
and to tune those models.
For developers we have the cognitive service APIs
and we should do even better coming up with Visual
Studio type of the tools
so that we can actually help you
put together a project
and the debugs, the whole process.
And then compile that, and take all kinds
of framework to compile it together,
all the way to different
kind of running platforms.
Like you know, Azure, Azure GPU
or even your home machine.
So those things I think
we have a responsibility.
Maybe the last thing I can share with the audience
is that we as a company of course struggle
to train our own AI talents,
so much so I decided to start
an AI school several months ago.
It turns out to be a huge success.
Everyone wants to learn AI.
And of course, we want to train every engineer,
developer to become an AI engineer.
We would love to learn from you
the best practices and even partner together.
- Great, thanks, Harry.
Fantastic.
So let's open it up to questions.
We have various roving mics,
so just put your hand up.
Somebody will give you a microphone.
We have somebody here.
Number 3.
- Hi, Julie Rockmore,
University of Illinois.
I was just wondering whether you could expand
a little bit more
on what you see the role
of academia to be,
and what we can do as faculty?
- Well that's a big question.
The way we look at that is Microsoft Research
has had a very rich history
of collaborating with many universities
and many university professors.
I feel very honored to have many of you choose
to come to visit us at this time
and coming to our Faculty Summit
to have a chance so that we can exchange ideas,
and then we figure out things,
even more things
that we can work together.
For Microsoft, and especially for Microsoft
Research, you know we're very open.
We do a lot of projects
and we write a lot of papers.
Many of those papers we jointly do
with the professors and the students.
I don't really have anything that specific,
in general how professors
should work with us
or work with others.
I think everyone has a different situation.
I don't know.
Chris do you want to add something?
I know you do things very successfully,
like work with some universities in Europe,
like the recent announcement
with Amsterdam
might be a great example,
you can share that.
- So I think this collaboration
with the academic world is a very deep one
and incredibly important.
And I like to think that
it's mutually beneficial.
As Harry mentioned, just last week
we announced another collaboration,
this is with Max Welling,
the University of Amsterdam,
under really sort of
two threads to this.
One is around this talent pipeline.
So really trying to partner with academia,
because it's in everybody's interest
that we really have a strong talent pipeline
with the next generation
of AI researchers coming along.
So one of the things we do with Amsterdam,
but actually more generally across Europe,
is we fund actually a very large
number PhD students,
but we don't just
fund the students.
I think more importantly, we are actually
almost all of those students
are co-supervised
by researchers in MSR.
And so it's a way of sort of adding
some intellectual horsepower
that augments that available
in the universities,
and also helps the students
get a little bit
of more of an industrial perspective
as well to complement
the academic perspective.
And then, so that's one strand.
And then the other strand
is on the research side,
where we're looking at some of the really
cutting edge, the futuristic,
the very long-term
aspects of things
around machine learning in AI.
Where we see really complementary strengths
in the case the University of Amsterdam,
tremendous strengths in areas
around unsupervised learning
and rich probabilistic
models combining probabilistic
methods with deep learning.
Looking at things like causal
discovery from data and sure, we have expertise in
MSR in those areas.
But you know, this is a vast
and very active field
and we can't do
everything on our own.
And so these partnerships
are incredibly beneficial.
So I think those two things,
both the talent pipeline
and also the research collaboration
are just incredibly
important to us.
Who's next?
OK.
Yes.
Number two.
If you just give us your name and affiliation
as well, that would be fantastic, thanks.
- Hi, I'm Barbara
Grosz from Harvard.
So you can tell by my gray hair that in a few decades
I'm going to retire.
And the advice for people retiring
is to diversify their portfolio.
So I'm seeing that you're making
a really heavy investment in deep learning.
You can also tell from my gray hair
that I've been an AI for even more decades
than MSR has existed.
And I I've seen these trends where
there's one technique that's everything.
And deep learning is doing great things.
But I'm wondering how diversified
do you see your portfolio of AI being,
both in terms of the research
and in terms of your school?
- Well listen to my talk tomorrow.
That's part of the answer.
I'll let Harry
- Why don't you finish your answer first,
and then I will
complement yours, yeah.
- Yeah, so you know, deep learning
has been undoubtedly a breakthrough.
So there are things that we now do
with much higher levels of performance
than we did before.
I think probably that breakthrough in deep learning
has really rejuvenated the whole field,
and in some sense, the reason we're excited
about AI is because of that.
However, the idea that everything can be solved
by just shoveling label data through a deep neural
network will of course
be completely naive.
So I think it injects a lot of energy
and enthusiasm into the field which is fantastic.
I also think that it offers a new building block
that we can combine with other techniques,
and that can amplify
those other techniques
and can advance the whole field.
But it's certainly not on its own a complete solution
to all the things we want to achieve.
So yes, I'll be giving a talk tomorrow,
a keynote in which I'll talk about
a somewhat broader perspective
on machine learning
that hopefully will help
answer the question.
- I add a little bit.
Well first of all, Barbara,
welcome to Microsoft again.
You know we love you.
You should come to visit us more often.
And Eric always talks about you,
and to send more students to us.
I really think that, you know, we first of all should
thank deep learning for it's incredible contribution
and the impact
in the field of AI.
There's a lot of excitement
because of that deep learning.
In certain areas it actually worked beautifully
in speech recognition and vision recognition
and other things like
deep reinforcement learning.
I don't think people are naive thinking that
deep learning is going to solve every problem,
and I don't think people
feel that way.
But until we actually can build the tools
that incorporate a lot of interesting
deep learning models to a way
that millions
and millions of developers,
engineers can easily do that,
it is just like solving second order
in the differential equation,
or whatever.
I think that until then,
people will still be mystified.
You know, what this deep learning really is,
and what's really going on?
I hope that we, in the next few years,
will be able to contribute
with great tools coming from Microsoft.
If you really look at
what's happening in deep learning,
a lot of those efforts
has been really
on the kind of architectural design
of the deep neural nets
that actually can perform
better than others.
And then you think about really deep
intellectual contributions coming out of the field.
They do have something like, you know,
generative adversarial networks and a few things like that.
I'd love to see even more.
I think maybe we should do more deep learning research
if we see more coming out of that.
But still you have to go back
to those fundamentals.
Many of those things
that Eric talked about.
We certainly diversify in MSR AI the areas
that we focus on, get to the deep understanding
of what is intelligence?
What is cognition?
How did you really build the models?
So that's what we do here.
- Great.
Fantastic.
Who's next?
- In the back.
- Right in the far corner in the back is somebody.
OK.
Number three.
- Hi, David Karger, MIT.
So what's been striking me today
in a lot of the presentations is how a lot of the work
that's going on in AI
is about getting computers to do things
like reading or having a conversation
that relatively untrained humans
are actually quite good at.
And I wonder if you could talk a little bit about,
I mean, we know that the downsides
of that for the future
of work and things like that,
but I wonder if you could
talk a little about ways
that AI might complement humans
and empower them to do things
that they can't do,
as opposed to replacing things
that they're already pretty good at?
- Maybe I will start it,
and then Chris, you can add more.
So thank you very much, David.
I hate to use this marketing slogan,
but that's the marketing slogan
we use at Microsoft
when we talk about the Microsoft AI.
We say Microsoft AI is all about
amplifying human ingenuity.
It's really about adding more value
to humans.
We talk about, it's all about the reason
we actually do Microsoft AI
is about the man and machine partnership,
something that Chris,
Eric and others from
MSR have helped our CEO,
our senior leadership team,
to really frame what we really do there.
I think there are numerous examples
where that AI adds value there.
I'll give you a very trivial example that, you know,
I just showed this morning
at our internal event
this morning out in Vegas,
is actually this intelligent camera app.
So it was something we actually released
about a year ago, it is called the Microsoft Pix,
it's an intelligent camera app.
It has a lot of interesting
technologies there.
In fact, we use the 20 some papers in the company
from MSR, and I put all those text there.
But I'll give you one example
that is actually if you use this app,
you take a picture of anyone,
I guarantee you your eyes will be open.
So is this a reasonable example?
So how do you guarantee when you take a picture
of someone that this person's eyes are always open?
And it turns out that we have already had
this kind of computer vision,
machine learning techniques there.
The way you do that is you
really take the longer sequence,
typically we take 10 frames,
and the chances are,
you are not going to blink that long.
- That's actually a perfect example
of replacing what a human can do.
- A human, if you take 10 pictures,
then a human can go through it
and find one with the eyes open.
- Well I think it's debatable.
I think Chris, you should add something
you have been thinking about
in a man-machine partnership,
and how we think about this at Microsoft.
- Sure.
I think first of all this idea
of artificial intelligence being a field
in which you list
all the capabilities of humans,
and then you cross them off one at a time,
achieve X and Y and Z, very dystopian, depressing.
What happens when you get
to the bottom of the list?
You know, that's very unappealing.
The other general thought is that it's true today,
and it's going to be true for at least
as far ahead
as I can foresee,
that the capabilities of machines
are very different and complementary
to the capabilities of people.
And we know that when you
combine things with different,
you know, when you combine
two classifiers together
with de-correlated areas,
the performance of the two together
exceeds that of either alone.
If you look at chess
playing machines, they can beat humans,
but actually the human and machine
together can beat any human or any machine,
the Centaur model.
I think that's true very generally.
So to give you a very concrete and sort of very
near-term example of a project
which was actually
in the tech showcase
is the project
called Inner Eyes.
So there what we're doing
is helping radiation oncologists
do radiation therapy planning.
That's a big deal,
because half of all of us
are going to end up
with some form of cancer during our lives.
- That's depressing.
- That's kind of depressing, and of those,
half of those are going
to need radiation therapy.
So it's a very big deal.
But to have radiation therapy,
you fire radiation in from multiple angles.
The idea is to dump as much
energy into the tumor as possible,
as little energy
into good tissue as possible,
and especially
into vital organs.
So you need a three-dimensional
segmentation of the tumor
and a three-dimensional segmentation
of your vital organs,
eyes and whatever else
there might be.
That's something which is currently done
manually by oncologists looking through
MRI scans, slice by slice,
and segmenting them.
It's tedious, it's slow.
The oncologist gets kind of tired
and it's not so reproducible.
It's screaming at for using machine learning,
that's exactly what the Inner Eye project does.
It's not trying to replace
the oncologist, it's trying to say look.
Here's a segmentation.
Instead of taking half an hour,
an hour, three hours in some cases,
in a few seconds it
gives the oncologist segmentation.
They can add then their expertise
and say actually, you know,
it's not bad but actually I can refine it
and tweak it a little bit,
using their experience
and in a few minutes
they've got a good segmentation.
And it frees up their time to be
doing things they should be doing,
which is thinking more qualitatively
about the whole tear pathway,
interacting with the patient.
And I don't know how things are
in the U.S., probably fairly similar.
In the U.K.
we're facing a shortfall
of around 4,000 radiologists,
and so we're really screaming
out for technologies
which can empower
those radiologists
to make them more efficient
and more effective.
Effectively, freeing up the stuff
that the machines are good at,
and leaving people to do the things
that they're good at.
So I see this complementarity
as intellectually much more appealing,
but also actually something
of an imperative.
Shall we just, we're kind of
running out of time.
Let's just take
one more question.
You get to the microphone first.
Number two.
OK.
Can you give us your name and affiliation?
- Pedro Domingos,
University of Washington.
So if you look at what's happened
with technology and business
in the last couple
of hundred years,
every time a major new
technology comes along,
it leads to a new kind
of dominant business.
So you know, like in the second half
of the 19th century it was the railways,
and then, you know,
when Ford invented the assembly line,
that was a whole new kind of,
multinationals were the product
of telecoms and air travel and whatnot.
And AI surely is one
such major new technology.
So the question is, what is that business,
what is the new kind of business
that is going
to result from AI?
How is it going to be different
from the businesses that exist today,
and how do we get there?
- Well I can give it a try.
At least to share some of the things
that we have been thinking about, Pedro.
One key thing along this line of AI,
creating all the business,
until now people do believe
that the magic is in the data.
So you have to have data
to make interesting things.
That could change in the future.
But this is where we see that.
So people do worry about that.
Does this mean that only the big five,
you know the top companies
actually have the opportunities?
The rich get richer,
and all this kind of thing.
At Microsoft, especially in MSR,
we have been thinking about this thing.
It was together with some economists
that we have been thinking about this.
And what particular angle we are actually thinking
about is what do we call the data as labor?
So that might be one very interesting way
to think about the future as a society,
as the economy, the business model.
You know, what does this
really even mean?
Because if you think about that,
especially and I was educated
by my colleague
Jaron Lanier,
you know if this whole ML thing
is going to really dominate,
would that be doomsday?
There's nothing
for humans to do.
You know, so we don't
believe that is the case.
Or, if you really think about, there
could be that the humans can continue to contribute,
especially the lower part
of the society income-wise.
You know, what can they really
contribute to society?
What should be the future
work for those people?
So I think that's one particular direction
that we actually think about it.
But it doesn't really mean just say,
you know, we're coming up with a new company
with one particular business model,
monopolize everything and making
most of the money.
It's actually more thinking
for the whole society.
- Great.
Thank you very much.
Well we really are definitely
well out of time there.
So I know there are more questions,
but I think we should probably wrap there
so we can all get off
and enjoy a nice dinner.
But many, many interesting questions
and whatever happens over the next few years
is going to be an extremely interesting time
for the field of AI.
I'm going to invite Sandy back
to make a few closing comments.
Before I do, could I just ask you to join me
in thanking Harry for a fascinating discussion.
- Thanks.